over the course of its short life
Germany's far-right AFD party has never
had it so good more than 90 seats in the
federal parliament and representatives
in each of the 16 regional assemblies my
guess this week here in Berlin is the
party's deputy leader georg paz deskey
what kind of party is the AFD growing up
to be
[Music]
gaile possessed key
welcome to complex on your federal
spokesman yog Myton says the AFD
completely rejects any form of
right-wing radicalism that's right
that's what he said he's right
this is patently untrue though isn't it
because last summer in various protest
rallies your supporters marched happily
alongside members of the anti immigrant
group pegida as well as Nazi activists
neo-nazi activist giving the Nazi salute
you want to choose either and about who
you were associating with where you know
this is not true because if your English
is not true but you didn't launch with
big either and no you're giving yeah but
but not see it should give me a chance
just to answer and this means no what
what happened in in Chemnitz was the
case that obviously the organizers of
the March didn't look very deeply into
it how to organize a march and this
means that certain groups which were not
part of the March joined the march but
on the other hand it's very clear there
is no place in the alternative doctrine
for right right-wing extremism or Nazis
or what you ever call and we are very
clearly a very strict we are the various
we are very strict on that yeah we have
the toughest procedures just to get new
members so for instance you have to tell
if you have been a member of party
before you are joining the aft of which
party if you have been for instance with
the national Democrats in Germany become
a member you cannot become a member of
the aft but you walked next to pegida
whose leader as you yourself has pointed
out has a criminal record including for
inciting hatred
he's called migrants cattle and scum you
were happy walking that your people were
happy walking no we are not having a
stadium we are not happy that this
happened but you can clean any device I
haven't been there others have been
there I would have expected I would have
expected that they should have said very
clearly that this
you are talking about Lutz Parkman
doesn't belong to this demonstration and
I made it very clear and also that I
think that that the board of the party
makes very clear that look Sparkman is
no partner for the FT certainly mistakes
have been made but we have to learn from
the future was it was a mistake you
party also justified the violence in
August when mobs chased and attacked
people who look like foreigners was this
just no no this is because now we know
there's fake news and if you're looking
really to the reports then you can be
this if this was not something that
there was a chase it was a video made by
people who have been joining or have joy
or joined the March and this was
announced by our government that there
was a chasing of people but this chasing
never happened one of you and for this
mean this means this means that fake
news are spread by people who trying to
bring the the AFD in a right-wing corner
what is Isis then when your own MP
Marcus phone Meir tweeted it is a
citizen's right to halt lethal knife
migration catchy phrase knife migration
isn't it after one nice incident
yeah only no no it's not only one knife
incident it's a no I cannot I cannot
number it out when I can say it's a lot
meanwhile and you professed we can you
know we can we can for instance for
instance I think if you want to talk to
each other you want to have an answer
then you should give me the chance to
answer
and this means certainly we have an
increase in crime rate and we have an
increasing rate of knife attacks in
Germany yeah this is this is pure
statistics and recede and it's by
microns and it's done and this means
that people have the feeling that
Germany becomes more and more unsecure
you see it is something only in the part
in the part of it is the part of journey
it's also in the western part you say
that was the past deskey the fact is you
go to
any lengths to turn the German public
against Muslim migrants won't you know
one of your posters
one of your poster campaigns featured a
smiling girl in a Czech dress right arm
raised leading a group of happy
light-skinned teenagers down at school
corridor underneath is the slogan Islam
free schools the poster was condemned by
the Bavarian Teachers Union as very
dangerous never given this country's
history I've never been this post and
I'm not aware of that post are you high
but on the other no I think I think the
position of the FT is very clear with a
the thumb doesn't belong to Germany but
certainly Muslims belong to Germany and
although they the position of the AFT is
that we certainly want to help people
yah who are looking for asylum because
we think yes we have to help people but
there must be a reason for a solemn
religious reason political reason other
reasons but what we expect or what we
are seeing in Germany and in Europe is
that we have migration because of AP of
economic reason mr. purselley is leap
over the borders we opened we opened two
borders without control which means
every funny could join everybody could
join Germany without being controlled
and this let the whole situation this
led to a situation that we have people
in Germany which every 15 or 20
identities this means and this means
schools is do you remember the Nazi sign
Jew free we never we never ever we never
said that we want to have Islam free
schools what we said is you did you put
it on between Islam we say school we say
nothing else but what's the Australians
say you like it
0:03 our country our rules you know I
don't don't think I don't know slogans
today I don't know if your way about
that I don't know if your way that we're
going to answer it yeah I don't know if
you're aware of my background my father
was polish and he was brought to Germany
in 1939 yeah for forced labor so just to
say
but I'm in a party where Nazis are this
is nonsense because I would never accept
this in this party but you'll and but
there are certain there are certain
people and I don't know if they belong
to the party who certainly use the party
just to to to to to spread their hatred
and other things and we have to do
something again it's very clear your
campaign against migrants Muslims have
mazed you which campaign I'm going to we
have to be country I'm going to give you
existence I'm going to give you examples
if you'll let me ask the question yeah
and do it it's made use of somehow
hugely exaggerated slogans like Europe
in the crosshairs huge Islamist attack
thought it occasionally some problem
schools have a hundred percent migrant
intake our teachers are being beaten to
a pulp yeah but but this simply isn't
true this doesn't if this is true so
leave early I don't know if you're
reading German newspapers but if you're
reading goose goose but if you are
reading German newspapers and use these
that we really have a problem we also we
have also schools in Berlin where you
have about 90 percent my microns yeah
which means ten percent of the pupils
are German and something is growing
dramatically wrong and there's many
teachers have been beaten to a pulp mr.
paderewski
I don't have a seat I don't I don't have
the statistics if this happened but what
you are doing is you are you're quoting
some things I'm quoting your propaganda
campaign no this is not my propaganda
campaign it's your party and it's it's
certainly not the AFT s propaganda
campaign I'm pretty sure about this you
are your pick you if you read you are
picking out some of I would say posts in
in in social media and then you are
saying it's the opinion of the AFT and
this is wrong yeah certainly you have
chosen deaths and read your name it goes
out no certainly not what you are doing
is you are you're saying some
you say this was posted by you yes but
you have no evidence tell me if
something is posted then there must be
somebody who did post it and I want to
have a name no I won't I won't you have
the name from you just to use Erick can
you give me the correlation what Islam
free schools mean in your opinion that
Islam is known then Islam rules that
Islam is not educated in a German School
where we have a Christian heritage is
this what you mean then I say yes
because Islam doesn't belong to Germany
and we are a Christian country we are
Christian cultural country and why
should be Islam educated in German Jules
it schools why we even have no religious
education in our schools why should we
teach Islam in our schools the process
key here some names for you about if
you're talking about the rhetoric and
the anti-migrant rhetoric one of your
leaders Alice Vidal yeah describe girls
who wore head scarves as useless she was
formally censured by the Parliament for
doing this Andre vent Member of
Parliament in Saxony inquired about the
cost for the state of sterilizing
unaccompanied refugee - think about it
you talk about your judeo-christian
heritage forcibly sterilizing children
what you are doing if this is really
unfair you are saying something no no
you're saying you say Ellis Vidal and
then you are going to a totally
different post and you are trying to
make a connection to Alice vital by that
and this is wrong
tell me maybe Ellis Vidal has said
something in the parliament I know
exactly the situation when she said
headscarf girls yeah Carla they don't
mages Coptic meeting and she said it she
said it she said it in the Parliament
and she was a sovereign and I was not
happy with it yeah but on the other hand
sometimes you have also to make very
sharp statements just to to describe
what is going on
were you happy when your leader
Alexander Gowland said about a black
member of Germany's national football
team Jerome Boateng
that he might be appreciated
for his role on the pitch but people
wouldn't want to someone like him as a
neighbor were you happy with that no I
was not happy with it because I think
it's nonsense
what was said and I I don't know why mr.
Gunderson's your leaders told that case
he in that case he talked nonsense yeah
because I think this is not true because
I think what you are trying to do is to
put us in a racist corner to put us what
you are doing is exactly what the other
parties in Germany trying to do and also
the media in Germany trying to do for
years and years yeah
just to put this means since FIFA five
and a half years yeah the the other
parties and all over the media trying to
push us in a in a Nazi corner in a
right-wing corner because this was in
the past always good means just to get
rid of a new party they did with a
Republican when Alexander Garland
described the Nazi period as a speck of
bird droppings in over a thousand years
of successful German history did you not
think how deeply insulting that must be
to the families of six million Holocaust
victims so then you have really to see
how he mended I talked to him and I said
oh happy with that come now I'm not I'm
not happy but but on the other hand know
what you know what you know what you
what you need to know is the point that
he mended in a different way he said
these were only 12 years yeah bad years
evil years but it was only 12 years and
there is a history of almost eleven
hundred years and we have also to
consider this if we are talking about
German so no one on the other side it
was a bet it was a very bad expression
what he did because it it has you can
interpret it in a different way I talked
to him and I also we had also a as it's
very
intense discussion in our board and we
made it very clear that you had that he
has to apologize for that
yeah that this was wrong what he said
yeah directly often while you are
telling everyone that you've no
connection with right-wing radicalism
and extremism you've allowed your youth
organizations to get seriously out of
control haven't you know we because we
have no connections to right-wing
parties or right-wing movements or what
so else
certainly we have currently a problem
with our youth organization with parts
only with certain people of our youth
organization but we are currently
looking you like and what you are doing
what we are currently doing is we are
trying to get a picture what is going on
and then we will have a meeting with our
board the party board and then we will
take certainly decisions on our youth
organization individualist and humane
and this yeah I know
yeah your and release it and we said
yeah absolutely and we said I'm part of
this present a release because I was one
of the of the creators they let it get
so bad in your party before you suddenly
said oh we need to do something about
this why did you let it get so bad you
have to get knowledge of it and then you
can react and if you have no knowledge
these are for instance and you cause
them you've accused them of abuse of two
to lower saxony for instance we
separated the youth organization of
laura's x oni we are looking into bremen
that may be the use organisation we
separate it what you mean looking are
you gonna expel them or not you have to
make a situation analysis yeah just
before you are coming to a decision you
have to know what was going on what has
been going on and then you need to make
a decision on a sound basis you see what
was going on for years
it didn't go on for years we get we got
knowledge one months ago for instance
and then we
we gave an order to our group which is
now investigating on that and if we have
the investigation closed then we will
make a decision if you have all the
information
a woman called Francisca Schreiber who
quit the board of the youth wing said
that as far back as 2014 half of all aft
youth members sympathized with the
far-right identitarian movement this
this this woman now she's afraid to eat
without a body that's such nonsense
because hardly arrived on scene because
because I know her and I know that she
was an admirer of mr. haka for instance
before she left the party she was by
herself very right thing and then she
didn't make any career in the party and
she left the party and now she is
talking about how evil the party is we
have always the same the same procedure
people who cannot make career in the
party leaving the party and then they
are yes just because she criticized you
you now say she couldn't make a career
she did very well she got onto the board
of the youth movement no this is not not
really a career what what this meant by
a career just to get a mandate just to
go into politics and she was not able
because nobody wanted to ever yeah
because of her behavior of her
background because of Riya yeah
proximity to to to to certain people in
the party and and this is exactly what
what is happening in this party that
people who who have a problem yeah and
who cannot make any Korean the party
they are leaving the party and then they
are announcing and then you've lacked in
their name when they do let's talk about
the manifesto that you put out last year
and something which one the the one
before the election which manifesto is
your twenty you're dissolving routine
and yes yeah your 20's emulation program
yes your party complained bitterly about
the state of political funding called
for a redefined and transparent system
but those calls are sheer hypocrisy
aren't they because the fact is you're
in the middle of a huge
financial scandal with your co-leader
Alice Vidal under what prosecutors have
called initial suspicion of breaching
Germany's party spending laws ironic
isn't it no no it's it's not a big
scandal because we paid back all the
money to those who spent the money
not according to investigation wdr you
can read the newspapers all the money
was paid back the investigation saw six
thousand euros was not paid back what is
six thousand euros out of a thirty
thousand no I think it's even more it's
one hundred thirty thousand and one
hundred something it's more than two
hundred fifty thousand year old Swiss
and two hundred suture yeah it was a
hundred thirty thousand also something
from from from a single Belgium was paid
so late it wasn't everything but it was
paid back and lost and it was paid back
by hours again we haven't been asked to
pay it back but we did it by ourself
this means certainly you can you can say
okay we could have paid it back earlier
but on the other hand there you should
really mean there is really no doubt
about it
then she reacted by ourselves you should
tell you I can tell you nothing will be
will be happening here you are you
banging the drum about how evil the
system is a party funny you break if you
break the room no we do you break the
rules nah we didn't break the rules we
palet sounded nobody should have been
paid back earlier yeah and then he says
I don't believe she should be blamed for
anything miss Vidal really you give
their address to your people who don't
know know that there there was no reason
to suppose look there was no rule broken
because for instance and the government
or those who are responsible for it they
didn't have any any periods in which the
money has to be paid back yeah this
means we react it in a way it's it's
totally legal what we did and we paid
some money back so if you are looking to
other parties yeah
we now have a head in in the Bundestag
mr. Schuyler who had was very deeply
involved in such fundings with mr. Cole
yeah and we it didn't happen to that to
the F if another party had done what you
have done this time you did it you would
be screaming from the rooftops now no
certainly you would be certainly on the
roof if they would have reacted in our
way then we wouldn't have scream it to
scream from the rooftops look at freedom
let's look at another part of your
program freedom of worship the AFD
pledges its unconditional support to the
freedom of faith worship and conscience
unconditional but there are conditions
there aren't they're in schools offering
Islamic studies the lessons to Muslim
pupils have to be given in German you
say and Islamic Quran schools should be
closed with immediate effect that's
unconditional
no no it's there are two choice you know
there are two reasons for it why I
should not be taught in Arab language
because young people especially young
people have to integrate in our state
yeah if they don't if they if they don't
manage the German language they will
have no chance in the future just to get
a job just to be educated and we are
seeing it currently for instance with
our Turkish minority with the young
people yeah you gave another reason in
your program and you don't you know
other reason because we see it that for
instance the young turk many young
Turkish people are not able to integrate
in our society because they have not the
the language skills yeah because they
have not lead the occasions they need
just to get a job and this is really a
problem for Germany it's the pastors
yeah no but you have the same problems
in Britain first those says you Islamic
Quran School she becomes you an
immediate effect as it's likely that
uncontrolled radical and
unconstitutional indoctrination takes
place there
it's nicely you don't say there are
there are it slightly wide true why is
the number there it's likely no no no
they are quite a number of quran schools
which are yeah over watched or guarded
by our for fasting shots which means
because something is going on in your
security our security because something
is going on in these schools that people
or young people are brought to
radicalize you I can give you a few
laughter that's not proof since when is
likely proof because there is there is
proof and I can give you the numbers and
the figures because what are the numbers
of the figures I have it in my head but
I can give it you afterwards
thank you yeah you will get it oh that
would be good test early so the
government says that your manifesto
violates the Constitution no your
religious family criminal and European
policies are in clear violation of
articles 1 3 4 and 23 of the German
constitution EU I don't know where you
got it but it's not true
yeah I won't say how many fests what
they said who says it it was the former
justice minister Heiko Maas who is Heiko
Maas party member he's no no no he's
speaking he's speaking as a member of
the Social Democrat Party which is
currently going down to 13,000 well sir
first that's very much present
government it's met us very much because
they are fearing the AFT because the AFT
is taking voters from the SPD from the
Social Democrats from the Christian
Democrats and also from other society
but is afraid of you are they yes
certainly thing I'm afraid because
because the point is we have actually we
have no unit we have really no no we
have really no party which is a
Conservative Party in Germany all the
other parties moved during the last
years constantly to the left side and
there was a vacuum right
on the right side besides the Christian
Democrats your feeling and your filling
that space exactly we are filling that
space lots of propaganda against no no
no it's not it's not a bird about
propaganda it's about telling the truth
yeah we need to say people that what is
going on and we are saying people what
is going on because we had a situation
in Germany said for years and years
people were not told the truth okay
all right mr. paczynski jo possess key
thanks very much for being here everyone
[Music]